development of the sequel to CD projekt
Red cyberpunk 2077 will begin in 2023
with pre-production once the team has
wrapped and shipped the original game's
upcoming DLC Phantom Liberty Adam
kasiski president and Joint CEO of CD
projekt Red says in its recent earnings
report that the team is finishing up
development of the expansion currently
of which almost 350 people are working
on thanks to the Netflix anime series
cyberpunk Edge Runners the game has had
a second wind as previously reported as
of September 21 remained one of the top
10 most played games on Steam that
earnings report which covered the third
quarter of business for CD project July
through September of this year revealed
that this was its best third quarter
since its founding in the 90s the
company brought in 54.2 million dollars
in Revenue thanks to strong sales of
cyberpunk 2077 which the company will be
looking to replicate in its sequel seems
like the dark days of the game's launch
are far behind in the rear view mirror
for gamers 2023 won't just be the start
of pre-production for the next cyberpunk
but may also bring a beloved entry in a
beloved franchise to consoles Capcom
apparently plans to bring Monster Hunter
rise to PlayStation 5 PlayStation 4 Xbox
series X and S and Xbox one next year
inside a gaming reported that the game
will release on January 20th on those
platforms as well as become available on
Game Pass followed by its expansion
sunbreak later in the spring Capcom will
supposedly unveil these plans at the
game awards on December 8th Monster
Hunter rise originally released in March
2021 for Nintendo switch with the game
now on PC as well what's interesting
about the news of it launching on a
console with Game Pass is that Xbox is
supposedly working on its own monster
hunter-like release according to a
report from earlier this year in January
Jeff Grubb of gamespot's sister site
Giant Bomb revealed that the title is
code named project suerte and is
underdevelopment at certain Affinity a
studio that is mainly done work
supporting other games including Xbox's
own Halo franchise of which certain
Affinity is also rumored to be
developing a battle royale game for its
latest entry Halo infinite Grubbs said
that depending on development the game
is likely to be revealed in 2023 with a
release later in the year or 2024
another game I'd like to hear more about
as soon as next year is bethesda's
Indiana Jones title which got a few new
tantalizing details from head of
Bethesda games Studios Todd Howard
appearing on Lex Friedman's podcast
Howard started off by saying that it's
internal Studio machine games which in
turn is now also an internal Studio at
Xbox is a quote perfect fit to develop
the new Indiana Jones game Howard
original originally pitched the game in
2009 but it didn't come together at the
time now that Disney is ramping up its
licensing deals Bethesda was able to
secure a deal and put machine games to
work on the game quote if you like
Indiana Jones it is a love letter to
Indiana Jones Howard who is an executive
producer on the title said in the
interview pressed to reveal exactly what
type of game the Indiana Jones title
will be Howard said it isn't so easy to
put into one particular category or
another quote it is a mash-up it isn't
one thing intentionally it does a lot of
different things that we wanted to do in
a game so it's a unique thing he said
are you looking forward to playing
Monster Hunter rise on next-gen consoles
are you looking forward to machine games
Indiana Jones let us know in the
comments and we'll see you here for more
Gamespot news